reports suggest that Ukrainian forces
have recaptured territory in the south
of their country it's their biggest
breakthrough there since the start of
the war Russian installed officials have
acknowledged Ukraine's advances in the
Hassan region that's one of four that
Russia illegally annexed last week
photos shared on social media appear to
show soldiers raising the Ukrainian flag
in several Villages unverified reports
suggest Ukrainian troops have advanced
as much as 40 kilometers in a single day
and let's get more right now from DW
correspondent Nick Connelly who is in
the Ukrainian Capital cave Nick very
good to see you this evening what can
you tell us about these latest advances
well it does seem like after months
where there was a lot of talk about
Corazon and where this always busy
turned out to be a distraction tactic
when actually Ukraine was making its
advances in the East and basically just
you know doing some incremental change
incremental movements so that this is
now really getting going Ukrainian force
is not only heading towards custom from
the west but also from the North and the
Russians are really exposed there they
are on the West Bank of the nepro river
this is a really really wide river that
is at its widest at that point and
Ukraine's been able to basically destroy
all the crossings and now Russia is
dependent on pontoon bridges and air
transit to get supplies to that Garrison
there so they're very very vulnerable
and there's a sense that you know
Ukraine is now really reaping the
rewards of months of Fairly kind of low
level and kind of methodological work at
trying to just destroy Russian supply
lines Russian arms Depots and now those
Russian soldiers are really suffering
from basically kind of starvation of
ammunition they're really you know
having to think three times about using
uh all kinds of weapon systems are not
really able to respond in kind to the
kind of barriers they're coming into
coming up against from the ukrainians
now moving in towards Carson
now this all sounds very impressive but
there is no doubt being heavy costs in
both terms of both human life and
material for the Ukrainian forces what
can you tell us about those losses and
what might that mean for their advance
well that's the thing the Ukraine
military keeps a very tight layer down
all these kinds of stats even in terms
of lives lost earlier on the conflict
let alone material and kind of weapon
systems I think the important thing to
bear in mind though is that it does seem
like those Western weapons deliveries
are getting here in time and
increasingly in larger volumes on
shorter time frames than was the big
case the beginning of the war and we're
seeing that those high mile systems
those rocket artillery systems that have
been so crucial to Ukraine's ability to
destroy Russian Logistics behind the
front lines they are still operating
near the Russian media has covered
supposedly stories about the destruction
the systems time and time again but you
know we see that they are still
operating that those stories are not
true and in terms of you know boots on
the ground there is no shortage in this
country people are willing to fight
you'll remember those pictures from the
early days of the war when you had huge
queues outside of the military
recruiting offices and that is still
largely the case what Ukraine needs are
weapons and more complex weapon systems
missile systems that can reach targets
further away from their positions but in
terms of the kind of equipment on the
level and the kind of complexity they
have so far it doesn't seem like they
are currently in a difficult situation
now that's everything on the
conventional side of the war but the
shadow of the Russian nuclear threat is
of course ever present how seriously are
people where you are taking that
I think for the longest time this was
kind of not taken seriously it was
deemed to be just a kind of empty threat
coming from Russian attempt to kind of
up the stakes rhetorically in a kind of
time where we're seeing Russian
conventional forces lose time and time
again on the battlefield and attempt to
maybe scare less the ukrainians who are
already dealing with Russia but maybe
the European countries that are sending
supplies towards Ukraine and you know
people were just discounting this for
the most part I think one thing that has
made people think have been statements
in recent Days by retired top U.S
generals
Petraeus we heard from Ben Hodges they
were basically kind of giving some
detail on what they would expect the U.S
response to be if nuclear weapons were
used they were they were very clear to
say they were speaking in a personal
capacity that they hadn't been told to
do so but the fact that we've seen these
two generals say fairly kind of similar
things and give quality of detail has
raised questions here in Kiev whether
there is a kind of signal being sent to
Moscow indirectly via these retired
figures and you have had reports of
people here trying to find out what to
do if nuclear weapons are used what kind
of strategies to employ what kind of
iodine tablets or other kind of measures
could help so there is a sense that this
is a real possibility but it's not
changing Behavior there's no sense that
Ukraine is now suddenly thinking about
coming to the table and kind of giving
in to Russian demands to avoid this but
it is definitely something that is kind
of you know forefronted people's minds
right now at a time where things are
really not looking good for Vladimir
Putin we'll have more on that that
response to the nuclear threats later
but for now we'll leave it there with
you DW correspondent Nick Connelly and
Kiev thanks very much
Ukrainian forces are also pushing on
with their counter-offensive in
northeastern Ukraine yet as Russian
forces withdraw from that region
evidence is emerging of what was a
brutal occupation
even is not coming back
months after he disappeared his mother
is still trying to figure out what
happened
he went to the forest with his friend
to pick up pine cones to light the
samavar
to make tea
and I never saw him again
she believes even was tortured in the
basement of this house
neighbors identified his body by the
jacket he wore from the local grain
Factory where he worked
he had this photo with him of us when he
was a boy
the town of isium was among the first
taken by Russian forces after the war
started
and it became a command center for them
they set up at least 10 torture sites
Andrei kotzar was captured shortly after
joining the Ukrainian Army
once his captors let him go he sought
shelter at a nearby monastery
they beat me only where my kidneys and
liver are rather than directly in my
face
and they beat the hell out of my back
but they tried not to leave any scars
most of isium has been destroyed
the city is without electricity gas or
water
many families rely upon humanitarian Aid
to get by
we're here to get clothes for our
children and food that's what we need
but despite the difficulties after
months of Terror under occupation life
seems to be slowly returning to the city